joão felipe sou especialista no mar
estática da antologia
mas a minha grande paixão é odontologia
social odontologia que eu acredito que
no brasil
talvez sim talvez não mas com certeza é
uma das áreas com a profissão que mais
se distancia os assistidos da
assistência
hoje no brasil nós temos um número de
dentistas do mundo perto de 305 mil
doentes com registros ativos
ao mesmo tempo nós temos mais de 22
bilhões de pessoas que nunca passaram no
dentista
então a gente tem uma hora mesmo
terceiro maior mercado de odontologia do
mundo só atrás dos estados unidos e da
china
e a gente tem de cada quatro idosos três
são os resultados totais
a gente está falando de pessoas sem
nenhum dente na boca
então esse é um panorama da odontologia
e eu queria contar pra vocês como
iniciou a minha história está dada por
um sorriso que aonde que o presídio
eu tenho o maior orgulho de fazer parte
e 2015 final de 2015
eu estava procurando algum tipo de
trabalho voluntário e eu achei uma
missão à áfrica onde hoje ocorreu na
parte da antologia e fui pra lá foi para
moçambique
cheguei em moçambique o brinco que é uma
brincadeira mas eu falo pra todo mundo
me pergunta que deus falou de algumas
histórias pra você de gerir e voltar
para sua casa para sua bolha em são
paulo e lá no primeiro dia de viagem
eu tava com uma roda de crianças tinham
50 crianças e perguntei pra ele como é
que eles colocam os dentes essa sim
dessas 50 crianças é uma comunicação
difícil que se fala português em
moçambique a língua oficial mas não é
todo mundo que fala antes de perguntar e
eu estava conversando sobre os hábitos
deles nem perguntei quantas quem daqui
têm escova de dente 3
crianças levantaram a mão e eu perguntei
mas como é que você escova os dentes com
o dedo e terra aquela história me marcou
muito
fiz a distribuição de escovas de dente
para todo mundo e eu sempre me emociona
ao contar essa história
a distribuição de escovas de dente para
todo mundo
as crianças pegaram passou uma meia hora
uma criança e me pedir para ele ele já
ganhou
ganhei eu falei você já ganhou
elmo's umbu o zoom de tudo pra quem não
sabe o que é mais um dos africanos
chamou demos um gol em branco o branco
europeu que foi o continente
tirou tudo tira até hoje e ele chama a
gente demos um gol e eu uso um ganho de
tudo começar a bronca é secreta no
primeiro dia de viagem da bronca essa
criança e começará a chorar e eu falei
porque está chorando tio ele vendeu
escova de dente
eu falei porque vendeu sua escova de
dente e crianças chorando e virou pra
mim e falou eu troquei por uma fruta que
é irmã não come há dois dias
então eu conto essa história sempre que
talvez ela seja o precursor o motivo do
sorriso existir ea gente vive hoje num
mundo tão com exemplos ruins
e a gente está precisando de exemplos
bons já emendou
contando uma história de que esse sou eu
no meio fazendo também distribuição de
escovas de dente uma época que a áfrica
vive a maior seca dos últimos 30 anos a
gente fazendo a distribuição de escovas
de dente o que é muito difícil porque
você distribui escova de dente para quem
está passando fome é 11 uma conta que
não fecha
fazendo distribuição de escovas de dente
distribuir para todo mundo conseguimos
através de uma parceria como essa
distribuição de leite leite em pó para
pessoas que estavam com fome começou a
virar um caldeirão
eu nunca senti medo trabalhando com
social
nunca nem esse dia isso começou a virar
uma um caldeirão as pessoas puxando você
pela camisa querendo comida
nesse turbilhão todos os voluntários com
muito receio começar a correr entrado
para uma igreja onde era nossa base
as pessoas entram pela janela pedindo
comida e eu lembro que todo mundo
pegando as malas correndo para entrar
numa van e eu deixei cair todo meu
dinheiro no mundo todo meu dinheiro do
bolso e uma criança de 10 anos com todo
o meu dinheiro do tio deixou cair no
conto essa história também pra mostrar
que o mundo tem jeito que a gente pode
sim fazer uma transformação social que é
o que hoje após o riso faz a gente como
sociedade
ainda mais hoje no brasil com essa
intolerância que nós vivemos
eu acredito sim que a gente pode fazer a
transformação ea por um sorriso e eu
como dentista posso usar as minhas mãos
e as oportunidades que eu tive para
devolver para a sociedade de alguma
maneira por essa educação esses
privilégios que eu tive desde criança
então eu sempre falo é que a gente a
gente não cuida de dente
a gente cuida de gente é muito diferente
essa peça é essa foto de contar pra
vocês vim aqui mais para compartilhar
algumas histórias pra vocês
o thiago talvez não lembre de mim mas eu
nunca mais vou esquecer dele trabalho
que a gente fez no sertão da bahia
um menino de 12 anos sem os dentes da
frente
na verdade 17 presente com 12 anos
[Música]
colocamos na cadeira fizemos atendimento
e sentiu perdido ainda
eu acabei de fazer o sorriso dele não eu
né equipe a ong entregou um espelho por
thiago thiago olhou foi carlos chagas
que não gostou do trabalho que é que eu
fiz e ele ficou muito quieto muito
estranho
acho que rolou e foi embora de repente
vê a mãe do tiago depois de meia hora
quero saber quem é o responsável pelo
projeto
eu achei que ia tomar uma bronca
conversar com você
thiago perdeu os dentes com 12 anos em
um acidente de bicicleta todo natal e
todo aniversário thiago pediu para
colocar dente nele e eu não tenho como
fazer isso ou tem dinheiro pra pra comer
pra viver sempre pra ele que deu se um
dia eu já vinha trazer essa solução
quando vocês eu não estou falando de
religião ou de algo muito maior
acho que a religião não é agente fechado
em uma caixa quadrada é muito maior que
isso
isso marcou demais e ela emocionada
falou não tenho como pagar isso pra
vocês mas eu posso dar isso ela me deu
um saco nesse saco tinham goiabas conta
essa história também para mostrar que a
odontologia não tem as pessoas não têm
acesso a isso
isso eu não podia um reflexo de que a
sociedade nossa hoje em dia acredito
muito em solidariedade às brasileiras
trabalho social
vocês terem idéia hoje no 4 - de 4% dos
brasileiros fazem algum tipo de trabalho
voluntário em contrapartida nos estados
unidos esse número beron perto dos 25
por cento
a gente tem essa
essa característica de falar que o
brasileiro é um povo solidário
mas quando a gente pensa nessa parte da
solidariedade trabalho social brasileiro
não é tão solidária assim
e é isso que a gente quer conectar as
pessoas a gente quer fazer com que as
pessoas sejam mais humanizadas
eu acho que eu gosto de uma frase que
diz que somos muitos somos seres urbanos
- humanas
a gente está precisando de humanização
então alta tecnologia que a gente faz e
eu prego que eu falo por aí pelo brasil
viajando
é isso esse contato com pessoas com
seres humanos
ali não tem uma boca pra você tratar e
não é um dente
ele é uma pessoa tentando sintetizar em
15 minutos
o que eu falo em uma hora e meia
e esse tipo de trabalho que a gente faz
já viajamos após o riso hoje já chego em
nove estados chegam dois países querem
moçambique
a gente tem a ideia para 2019 chegar
mais longe
então é um trabalho que eu sou
apaixonada
sou apaixonado pelo social eu queria
conectar o coração de muitas pessoas que
todo mundo desce junto com a gente então
esse é um caso que a gente fez no sertão
também trabalha com o social e com
crianças à primeira cavaco pesa é a mãe
né mas quando você parar pra escutar a
história de cada mãe só porque a boca
dessa filha tá assim a culpa da mãe
amanhã ele trabalha 12 horas 3 horas
para colocar comida em casa maura
consegue ficar com silas a gente
consegue chegar nessas pessoas
muita gente fala a philips enxuga gelo
você enxuga sei lá fica a áfrica cuidar
dessas crianças vai pro sertão vai para
as comunidades ribeirinhas e você volta
para sua casa
não mudou nada não é isso que a gente
acredita acredita realmente que a gente
pode fazer a diferença
se você não está do lado do oprimido
você tá na hora do professor
a gente não pode empurrar pro para baixo
do tapete
a gente tem cinco por aqui que devolver
para a sociedade de alguma maneira
tudo tudo o que a gente tem é teve
acesso estudos em educação
então essa é a forma que encontrei diz a
odontologia para poder fazer isso
ou seja alguns casos desculpa nervosismo
eu sou só um dentista dentista e esses
ser só um dentista para mim mostra que
todo mundo pode fazer então a gente pode
não a gente não precisa de divindade
nenhuma as pessoas escrevem pra mim
falar nossa você é bonzinho você tem
muita luz
eu não sou bonzinho não tenho muita luz
é uma questão de justiça social é muito
além as pessoas têm que ter oportunidade
então a base da pirâmide quer maior da
sociedade não tem acesso
é isso que a gente quer desconstruir são
essas pessoas que a gente quer chegar
hoje por um sorriso chegou nem perto de
10 mil atendimentos odontológicos
então a gente quer atender onde tiver um
sorriso para despertar a gente quer
falar
sorriso que a gente busca não só isso da
boca ações da alma um sorriso muito além
é isso que a gente está buscando não
importa o lugar
muita gente fala você vai para a áfrica
para poder fazer isso a gente pessoas
são pessoas em qualquer lugar não
importa a etnia cor classe idade
são pessoas estão saindo pra áfrica pra
goiás pra qualquer lugar são pessoas
então eu quero deixar para vocês que
essa
essa frase é que é possível a gente
fazer o bem
basta a gente querer que o lugar é o
sofá não é o melhor lugar pra quem quer
mudar o mundo
se a gente quer mudar o mundo a gente
começa a provocar uma mudança nessa
mudança e nós e reverbera isso para a
sociedade que as pessoas que estão à
nossa volta e para a nossa comunidade
para o nosso país
a gente está numa época muito difícil
então a gente reclamou muito e faz pouco
então eu falo assim o sofá é o melhor
lugar para quem quer mudar o mundo
obrigado gente
[Aplausos]